Stephen Miller is a senior advisor was
for four years to president Trump he
implemented many of the policies that
the Biden People canceled he joins us
tonight Stephen Miller thank you so much
for coming on so it's a little when you
look at pictures of what's actually
happening at the border when you see the
numbers five million people in two years
totally changing the American population
how could Tom Tillis and murkowski and
Romney how could they support
giving an amnesty in the face of that
because they support unlimited
immigration into this country they
believe fundamentally as a philosophic
matter that Americans aren't up to it
Americans can't cut it the American
middle class is no good its values are
useless its history is useless it's
aspirations mean nothing to them like
the dirt that you walk on the ground so
of course you need to bring in new
people and I would say that on the
dreamer Point specifically it is the
most Insidious form of amnesty that any
country could ever consider because the
message to the world is smuggle a child
into this country and that child will be
rewarded with U.S citizenship and what
you will have and what we're already
seeing is a wave of illegal miners being
brought into this country of biblical
proportions just to put this into
numerical perspective in 2020 when we
use title 42 to adopt a 100 percent
repatriation policy for minors
we achieve the lowest levels of minor
Crossings since pre-obama amnesty times
you talked about DACA in your opening so
before that no one had ever seen numbers
that were that low of miners before this
whole thing started then Biden came in
and despite warnings from border patrol
he said that miners are exempt from
title 42 the automatic expulsion policy
we have now seen almost every single
month under Biden let this sink in
almost every single month under Biden
the number of unaccompanied minors who
have entered the country is higher than
every single month in American history
before Biden every month almost without
exception is higher than any month in
all of history before Biden and in that
environment Cinema and Tillis and others
are saying let us codify the idea that
smuggled minors are Americans for life
it's insane Tucker well I mean it's it's
encouraging human trafficking Tom tell
us that's what you're doing and you know
that's what you're doing but you're
doing it anyway Stephen Miller
appreciate you coming on thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight